I don't know how much you know about me
but I have had a lifelong obsession with
Abraham Lincoln since I was a kid true
story I've read everything I can about
Lincoln and of course Illinois is the
land of Lincoln Lincoln spent Lincoln
spent most of his adult life in
Springfield Illinois so a few days ago I
flew to Springfield to visit several of
the Lincoln's sites around town we
brought a camera along here's what
happened hey this is exciting we're at
the Abraham Lincoln Presidential Museum
it's in Springfield Illinois they've got
everything here they've got right behind
me a life-size recreation of Abraham
Lincoln and his family his wife and his
kids and behind them hanging around in
broad daylight John Wilkes Booth just
looking like a creep I don't know why
they didn't catch him he's right there
I'm here now in the Gift Shop of the
Lincoln Presidential Museum they've got
some good stuff there's this t-shirt
which depicts cool laid-back Lincoln
there's also nerd Lincoln
the Emancipation Proclamation shot-glass
one of the greatest pieces of
legislation in mankind's history and you
can drink tequila out of it any hats
gonna get you laid
it's the I heart history picture shows
Lincoln on acid this is Lincoln just
after he went to a concert a really rad
concert and then looked into the mirror
this is what he saw Lincoln's last night
I think it's a porno I've actually seen
a little bit of this it's pretty
incredible very dirty
well we finally found it the least
convincing fake beard ever man look at
that it's also this was used by John
Travolta I'm standing in front of the
old Statehouse where Lincoln used to go
and stand in line at the DMV trying to
get his license renewed no visit to
Springfield Illinois is complete without
meeting with not just one but multiple
Lincoln's mr. president mr. president
Thank You mr. president and mr.
president am I correct you also in your
spare time played Lyndon Johnson you had
me wrong you're a lawyer Lincoln
yesterday
okay that's one question that irritates
me the most is where's your beard and
then you get mad I'm lawyer Lincoln I'm
sick of talking about this lawyer
Lincoln do you ever feel that urge to
change into your Lincoln outfit just
like a superhero like you see is
something going on and you have your
Lincoln costume in your trunk you just
want to put it on and go now hold on
fellers I was tempted one time riding
the bus to a performance in Iowa there
was a little altercation between two
passengers one gentleman claims that the
other one had used for racial slur
fortunately the bus driver pulled the
bus over and told them both it into hey
them sell shoes we'll throw them off the
bus so wait you're linking on a bus you
see a racial dispute and you did nothing
I'm sorry that's just that's a bad story
Abe that's a bad story well I don't like
to get involved I was one of these
things tend to work themselves out get
some woman take care of this I'd like to
now introduce you to Mary Todd Lincoln
Mary would you come in here please
nice to see you how are you now Mary
there are four bachelors here and well I
was dreamed of marrying the president
that was always a goal of mine oh are
you in character now are you being
yourself I'm scared okay
well now yes well you can't see right
now but I'm pushing a panic button with
my foot and the police are coming
Steven Spielberg is making a new movie
and it's gonna be it's a time I
anticipated about Abraham Lincoln he's
chosen Daniel day-lewis to play Lincoln
you're just hearing the news for the
first time and seem enraged you found
Mary Ann I'm okay with it but I just
wish it would have been me how come
Daniel day-lewis just gets to walk in I
know Stephen Spielberg and when I say
know him I know where he lives and I can
get over that where do you want to look
into camera and make a plea to Steven
Spielberg mr. Spielberg checked out my
website Lance presents my four score and
seven years ago my website went down for
26 hours now gentlemen I did take the
liberty of bringing my own Mary Todd
Lincoln impersonator here Mary would you
step in here please
Mary gentlemen what do you think of my
Mary table
you're portraying Mary Lincoln when she
was on Maxim magazine oh yeah totally in
Maxim's Katie who's a little
underdressed right here okay the handoff
there look at this guy here this guy's
got his creepy peeper glasses on hey
those are fogging up mister is that what
Abe would do when he would see this Mary
dress like this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]